-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
CNN has reported that a lawyer
for former vice president
Mike Pence
found a dozen
classified documents last week
at Pence's Indiana home.
Okay, so they're just
in every home?
That's the only thing
that makes sense anymore.
When you buy a new house
and you move in,
there's just classified
documents sitting on the counter
next to that half roll of paper
towels and box of baking soda.
President Biden is expected to
spend the weekend at Camp David,
and you know
it's been a rough week
when you start making
your weekend plans on Tuesday.
[ Laughter ]
The Justice Department
is reportedly considering plans
to search other locations
connected to President Biden
as part of its investigation
into his handling
of classified documents,
which could include everywhere
from Cold Stone to TCBY.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new poll,
nearly 60% of New York voters
think Republican congressman
George Santos should resign,
while according to him,
180% say he shouldn't.
[ Laughter ]
That's his poll.
That's his internal polling.
A newly surfaced video
appears to show New York
congressman George Santos
saying that he survived
an assassination attempt.
I guess we can't be surprised.
There's always someone
gunning for you
when you're the star
of the volleyball team
at Baruch College.
[ Laughter ]
Former FBI official
Charles McGonigal
was arrested over the weekend
on charges of money laundering
and violating sanctions
against Russia
while working with
a Russian oligarch.
But remember, under our system,
McGonigal is innocent
until Trump calls him
a good man.
[ Laughter ]
A South Carolina woman
recently used winnings
from a scratch-off
lottery ticket
to purchase a Powerball ticket
and won $150,000
in what financial experts
are calling
still a smarter investment
strategy than crypto.
[ Laughter ]
Candy company Mars
announced yesterday
it will replace its
so-called M&M's spokescandies
in upcoming ads.
Luckily, the green one's
got another gig lined up.
[ Laughter ]
"You melted
in my husband's hands."
[ Laughter ]
Authorities in Spain recently
raided a tobacco factory
accused of exploiting workers
and seized $41 million worth
of leaves and cigarettes.
And to teach them a lesson,
they're going to make them
smoke every last one of them.
[ Laughter ]
I should make whoever wrote that
smoke the joke.
[ Laughter ]
Roll it up.
And finally --
Oh, it's Scollins.
Thank you. Wally went back
to let me know who wrote it.
He wanted to make sure
I could shame him by name.
[ Laughter ]
Mike Scollins.
If you're watching,
which you probably aren't,
go smoke your joke.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, after
Disney World's Splash Mountain
officially closed yesterday,
containers of water from
the ride are being sold on eBay,
including one listing
for a four-ounce bottle for $4,
which is still way cheaper than
buying a water at Disney World.
And that was the monologue,
everybody.
We're off and running.